all right let's finish up with one last
story that celebrates our love of
reading this is what I'm liking
[Music]
[Applause]
hello book not a tablet that makes
reading that much more enjoyable uh
don't you agree it's a real it's
tangible it's nice it smells good it's
nice every year though there are fewer
Librarians working in public schools in
fact there are fewer libraries and
schools at all so in Nebraska nonprofit
is working to put physical books in the
hands of every school kid whenever they
want one it's called dibs for kids and
it recently won an award from the
Library of Congress
here to explain let's say hi to Angie
watching on KETV what's up Angie
hi Kelly hello so this isn't a library
can you explain how it works yeah so
dibs for kids which stands for
delivering infinite bookshelves for kids
provides High interest representative
diverse books in elementary schools
throughout Omaha we work with 5 000
students here and what we do like you
can see in this picture students every
day come into their classroom pick out a
physical tangible book take it home to
read come back the next day check that
book in pick out another book for
themselves and that means that you know
the kids can discover the joy of reading
they take home about three books a week
on average and we're just thrilled to be
on that reading Journey with them it's
really incredible what you're doing
there's a lot of ground to cover though
right there is a significant amount of
ground to cover like you said libraries
are every year there's fear but you know
what we know that bringing more books
into classrooms lets kids really
experience that Joy of reading we know
it helps kids gain
um further reading proficiency get back
up to grade level and so really being
able to be in the classrooms really
helps divs and those students
specifically can make up all of that
ground and like I said we just are so
thrilled to be able to help all of those
students here in the Omaha Community
well it's incredible it's amazing what
you're doing for all those kids thank
you so much Angie I'm liking your post
right now right
yeah thank you so much I appreciate it
absolutely and that's not all girl our
season long partner pilot pin makers of
friction the go-to RICO pin of the Kelly
Clarkson show want to celebrate those
instilling the love of reading to all
just like you so they're giving dibs for
kids a thousand dollars how's that sound
[Applause]
it was amazing we appreciate it
absolutely Angie have a great day and
thank you to all of our guests this hour
Jane Fonda Candace Berg and Diane Keaton
Mary's team virgin and Caitlyn Smith
y'all have a great day and it's not
maybe get lost in a book and try and
make your day better
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody